pornhub which apparently is a website I
had no idea about that
they released extensive data about porn
watching habits and the geographic
locations of where people are watching
and what they're watching let's look at
this fancy map okay so you many of you
guys are gonna have to pause this and
really take it in because there's a lot
there let's really leave this up now I'm
gonna give you another image in a second
that's going to show you the
state-by-state but just look at some of
that so in New York they're going for
the college porn Florida and many of
these other states in the South you're
getting cream pop Google yeah so I had
to google it to Ben do you know what do
you know
highs maybe they're using cream puffs
yummy corn so I'm not going to explain
all right we can get off that map for a
second I'm not gonna believe it
just go back to that I mean oh what'd I
just see screaming at me is Texas okay
we're gonna get so let's jump to the
let's jump to the next image here and
this is the state breakdown so Montana
and Oklahoma they love the but it's anal
they all of it
Kentucky and Virginia love hentai yeah
do you want to explain what gente is all
I could come up with from the Wikipedia
was that it's it's crazy Japanese porn
it'd make it crazy animation creation
yeah anime anime okay let's go back West
Virginia loves large ladies that's bbw
for those keeping track at home the west
coast is really into agent W big black
woman or is a big butt baby but like
women it's black women please yeah man
you've got the laptop there for you
alright then Ben's gonna work on that
Wyoming and Idaho have some strange
strange fetishes including smoking
cigarettes and back room casting couch
so I I mean this is really fascinating
that depending on where you live in
these United States of America that your
porn habits are different do you guys
read into anything beautiful one Oh big
beautiful in movies
that could be big black women it could
be big butted women and I mean you could
have the BBB W also so you ready I I
think it was interesting on that map
that we see it for one more time it's
really unimaginative if what you like
best is complete that's like a little
it's a little it's a lot of one thing
really like if you're like yeah I want
to see I here's how much I don't not
only do I not want a story I can't even
sit through a two minute stand right
just I just want the ending you just
well those know it's probably not
probably not those yeah but it's like
it's like you just want to turn on
Citizen Kane and just say oh it's a
sweat not to sweat fantastic yeah I
didn't want to see that slide do you
think there's anything we can learn
about this though from some of the
geographic stuff I mean even in the
South they see so there's the team thing
in Texas and they do seem to like black
porn more in the south is the hugely
black populations also so interesting I
was thinking I was actually thinking
about it the other way that because
there's more racial tension somehow in
the South that it's white people that
are secretly while the messed up thing
about calling it ebony is assuming first
of all black people can engage in all
the pornographic activities the white
people get you can actually you can
actually have a black copulation you
have your black cream pie and your black
teens your black Asians so yeah but but
I'm getting so they've sort of made
black one category which so I'm gonna
guess that's a that's gonna tilt it
slightly to states like South Carolina
which have forty percent black
population I think but that's it I'm
sure that you know there's plenty of you
know plenty of guys harboring either out
front or deep-seated racial animus who
are going home and then watching
blackboard okay whatever it turns out
black people have sex exactly the way
white people know what
yeah no we're done laptop you're telling
me that blacks is as boring and stiff
and Wow I totally lost my thought on
that I had pictured there were so many
things that I that I picture there what
do you think that disgust one of the
reasons I do these segments every couple
weeks on here is I do think porn has
become so mainstream but I actually
think there's something cathartic about
talking about it because everyone's at
home watching this on their computer and
this is still something that's done so
privately and yet everyone's doing it I
think it's important to talk about is
that crazy what kind of but really do
you think it's important at some level
to talk about something that was never
told about I'm always a huge fan of
talking about embarrassing things
because humans are horrible embarrassing
weird little people inside and we need
to talk about it and share our feelings
yourself i well you know it's a very big
danger in life it's what Republicans do
is they they extrapolate their own
experience to others like if I made it
you could make it right it's horseshit
you but I'm about to do it Bob
please I wonder whether we're getting
close to a moment of sort of
demystifying porn for lack of a better
term certainly demonizing it it's
probably better because there was a time
when if I watch something I would
instantly erase my history right right
and now I don't really care like all of
a sudden if you go on this computer and
you're like hey look what that was
watching you know I'd be like yeah you
know the NSA is watching anyway so you
know I mean the stigma is definitely at
least for me personally and maybe that's
just once you reach your 7000 video you
know I don't know I suspect we're
getting close to a point where we're
certainly the shame is removed at least
a little all right well there you go
we've removed the shame from porn
[Music]